un match pour se rapprocher du podium de
D1 de district les Bleus de voisins
recevaient les jaunes de Chatou pour le
compte de la 4e journée en première
période les deux équipes du milieu de
classement s'observent et ce sont
finalement les Catoviens qui ouvre le
score sur ce bel
enchaînement 1 à0 malgré les tentatives
des deux côtés le score n'évoluera pas
avant la pause on a fait une bonne
première mi-temp je pense voilà on
domine on gagne 10 à se mettre en route
mais on conède un but assez logiquement
première mi-temps au retour des
vestiaires voisin accélère pour revenir
dans la partie se procure plusieurs
occasions l'équipe locale est
récompensée avec ce petit bijou inscrit
à la 54e
[Musique]
minute voisin aurait pu l'emporter mais
le gardien de Chatou est attentif sur
chaque situation dangereuse score final
un partout les joueurs ont une très
bonne réaction sur la seconde mi-temps
et c'est logiquement qu'on vient au
score on aurait pu pousser un peu pour
aller chercher ce deuxième but mais on
s'en concenta pour aujourd'hui on fait
des bons matchs nos matchs sont
cohérents mais malheureusement on prend
pas les trois points donc on stagne un
peu dans le championnat on va essayer de
d'inverser çaah dès la semaine prochaine
en seconde voilà en seconde période on a
du mal à rentrer dans dans notre match
ensuite on prend un but sur une touche
sur une voilà une mauvaise mauvaise
appréciation d'O d'où valer le ballon
sur un marquage après félicitation
numéro 10 qui met un très beau but voilà
au classement les Vinois remontent à la
5e place du championnat les C vient sont
quant à eux 7e la prochaine journée est
programmée ce dimanche 29 octobre voisin
recevra l'équipe 3 du FC Mantois et
Chatou accueillera moropa